this thing right here I guarantee you if
you ever try it it'll be the tastiest
toggle you ever had you know what's up
my name is Gabriel that I has I miss
your tacos way today I'll be making that
cotton asada tacos way the talk of way
came from Malita crunchy tortilla melted
cheese meat onion cilantro red sauce
Bamako Mali man this thing is just like
full of flavor explodes in your mouth
tacos way it came from a slang word from
the street I come from Mexico from a
part where we use the word way all the
time
it means like hey what's up fool what's
up homie what's up buddy first of all
when I started talking the way I created
my own menu I used fresh quality
products great quality meat you know
people weren't coming in because it was
just a hidden little restaurant nobody
knew about with all the free time I had
I started getting into social media
making my own memes when I did my first
video that's what pretty much got me
known in the neighborhood and what that
did is it brought people to my
restaurant and they tried my food and
they were amazed because they were like
okay it's not only his page is pretty
fun but his food is also good they want
to come eat once and leave they will
come eat once and then want to come eat
again and again so tacos way came pretty
much from social media so my most
popular video the one that went viral
here in Mexico came from a song that
says I'm in love with the Coco so we
changed and we called it I'm in love
with the tacos so it goes like I'm in
love with that bad cool so and I just
blew up on us and blew up on me that
video it opened up the doors to many
other opportunities because not a lot of
people have actually I don't know
anybody that's done what tacos Way has
done before tacos way all selling hot
dogs outside of the DMV the best part of
the journey of tacos way is seeing the
kids love tacos way they want to be
tacos way they don't see like the
taquito being the stereotype of a short
fat Mexican under a cactus you know now
as a cool Mexican guy that knows how to
make tacos and making a good living
works hard takes care of the family
creates jobs that makes me so proud it's
a feeling that I can't
now that's a tacos way right there oh oh
yes the hot sauce the red sauce I think
I made a really spicy
[Music]